[Music]
I've been having this strangest dreams
Rachel dreams are not reliable
analytical material that's so 20th
century
[Music]
we're delighted to let you know that
we've had movement on
them we got a spot at the womb Center
but I haven't told Albie yet oh why
Rachel
thank you
[Music]
he wants a natural child
but hold on you put us on a wait list to
have a baby in a name even though it's
not an egg it's it's an egg
women are reluctant to have children
because it's not made convenient we want
them to pursue their careers and dreams
we can't live in the past I want to have
a child with you let's do it really yeah
[Music]
parents are raving about it it is the
ultra solution
my nephew was born at the boom Center
but he doesn't dream I wouldn't worry
about it
oh come on I can't do it with the pot in
here what are you talking about it can't
see us
I feel Alvey is able to bond with a
child but I'm not
maybe I'm just not ready to be a mother
you know no one's a mother just like
that you become one
lately I've been holding on
we are considering having a home birth
I'm sorry it's not possible I won't
raise this child without nature
congratulations
so exciting isn't it
I noticed a change in productivity you
do have a baby at the womb center right
why
[Music]
your family Dynamics are about to
undergo tremendous changes
how can we make sure our baby's not
bored in utero oh yeah we don't want any
bored babies